[Music]
hi I'm Mike Seymour from FX guide.com
for Wired near the end of this season of
Game of Thrones we saw one of the best
entrances and possibly the greatest ever
exits as the nearest escapes from the
grand reopening of the fighting pits on
dragon back but just mounting the games
and filling the stadium would have made
for a serious set of visual effects
shots with the extensive stadium
extensions crowd replication and digital
double work required when the fighting
breaks out while there were live action
extras there were only about 500 on the
day although amazingly 68000 applied for
that job the star of the scene is the
arrival of drogon who arrives to save
the day the dragon was designed and
built by pixar mundo an artist and
catch-up but animated here brilliantly
by Rhythm & Hues the dragon needed to
work with flying and attacking but the
real challenges were in the detailed
work on the ground here the team led by
VFX supervisor Joe Bower needed to
provide extreme close ups subtle and
moving facial animation and careful
integration with live-action with
flamethrowers controlled by motion
control rings the principal photography
was in the Plaza del Toro's in Astana
Spain with some 200 feet of green-screen
30 foot high built around the real-world
bullring although a storm blew that down
one night and the team had to finish up
King just off the clear Spanish blue
skies what makes the dragon animation so
strong is they built such a detailed
skeleton and underlying muscle system to
move realistically under the skin an
exceptional detail of the dragon's eyes
which ended up telling a lot of the
story and delivering the subtext of the
relationship the dragon was pre animated
and agreed upon in previous so the
camera department could frame up on what
is essentially an empty frame correctly
the unfortunate attackers who get killed
were a combination of stuntmen on pull
rigs and CG DG doubles though the real
flamethrower did in fact ignite the
stuntmen you see being burned to death
this sequence represented some of the
most elaborate and cinematic visual
effects in this season of HBO's Game of
Thrones and will no doubt go down as one
of the most loved sequences ever in this
powerhouse series we'll don't forget
please subscribe for more behind the
scenes action I might
Seymour for wide
you
[Music]